[Music]
today's question comes from john in
british columbia he said my wife and i
have three and a half years of car
payments ahead of us and our monthly
payment is 300 bucks we've got two kids
earn about 45 000 a year after taxes and
our budget is fairly tight with no
wiggle room we have roughly 20k and a
tfsa and oh 15k on the car you say to
use any non-retirement investments to
pay off debt but why should we use the
20k we saved which is making 10 interest
a year to pay off a payment which has
zero percent interest i don't see the
benefit of doing that especially since
it would leave us with almost no savings
interesting
not the first time we've heard this uh
this scenario dave
i could put my money in the market and
make way more than my debt is costing me
an interest
yeah
i mean here's the thing
um
you make 45 dollars a year
you have a 300 car payment that's
causing you stress
your best thinking has gotten you to
this point
so you're going to keep using your best
thinking
i have to ask myself those same
questions i mean
it's like you know i hired a personal
trainer one time to come to our house
and have a little gym in the bottom of
the house and sharon's making fun of me
you're paying somebody to help you count
to ten one two three you know and i'm
like it's not what it is and she says
well you don't listen to him you don't
do what he says he's got a six-pack you
got a keg i mean you ought to listen to
the guy
my best thinking got me a keg his best
thinking got him a secret are you going
to listen to so who are you going to
listen to your your best thinking or
someone else's yeah that's that's at the
core of this
and that's not because i'm offended that
you didn't just jump on this but you
know one of the things we have to do in
this
process is
uh go
my way is not working anyway i mean if
you keep making a cake over and over
again and you want chocolate cake and it
keeps turning out vanilla you need to
change the recipe yeah
doing the same thing over and over again
expecting a different result is the
definition of insanity so that's at the
core of this
um and then we can answer the question
too yes but then that foundation needs
to be there and what's happening here is
i love math as much as the next guy but
if you just do math you go wow this
works man i'm going to invest all the
money in the market and leverage all the
debt i can
but math is only part of the equation we
got to talk about behavior we have to
talk about risk we've got to talk about
options and freedom which he doesn't
have right now because he has a car
payment
and so if you want to have that freedom
you've got to make a sacrifice here
based on your theory john you would
borrow 300 000 on a car at zero percent
and put it all in the market at 10
and obviously when i say that out loud
you hear the absurdity of it and that's
how absurd your overall question sounds
actually
so um and the reason is you've left out
risk you've left out cash flow you've
left out peace
and so what i want you to do you can do
whatever you want to do but what we
would teach you to do is pay off your
car today
or sell it
if you're going to keep it if you're not
going to keep i mean if you don't want
you want to keep the money that's fine
sell the car
uh but but i'd pay it off today if i'm
going to keep it and then i would
continue to move through the baby steps
which puts you if that makes you debt
free then you're going to move towards
your emergency fund i'm building that up
and then you're gonna move towards
retirement accounts which it looks like
he'd have about five thousand left over
even after paying off the car so that'll
get him some headway into baby step
three so i'm not sure in british
columbia what a tfsa is i'm assuming the
way he asks the question that it is not
retirement account yeah um and so but um
but conceptually if it's not a
retirement account i'm pulling the money
and paying the car off where i'm selling
the car you need to get rid of your car
payment john
because it's but the other thing you got
to really think about is
my best thinking brought me here number
one that's not working number two um
you you have to ask yourself if the
information i'm getting somewhere else
is credible and if it is credible i'm
going to submit myself
to that new way of thinking
and so um
you know it can be just simply i was
reading a book on parenting when the
kids were little
and it said this this and this this and
i went well i have never done that i've
never even thought about that and i
thought
yeah but the source the author was
somebody i believed in
and i thought you know what he probably
knows more about it no no
so i'm gonna start doing that do it his
way you know after reading about 15 of
those books the kids turned out none of
them live in my basement so there you go
and so it means i'm a success right so
there you go
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five for you basement
dwellers you have to know uh that um
an eagle who fails to launch is
eventually known as a turkey
i like that one i don't know if i've
heard that that's where you go so
set the little eglets free it's good for
them little wings will develop and
turkeys get shot we will have society
and um yeah and we eat them at
thanksgiving yeah so there